séquence spéciale festival de cannes
maintenant avec france roche
ce soir elle s'est entretenue entre deux
sacs sur le sable fin des plages
cannoises avec gérard blain devenu
réalisateur avec son film un enfant dans
la ville franz koch
les estivales ont toujours leur conte de
fées le conte de fées 1976 celui qui a
valu à gérard blain metteur en scène
deux un enfant dans la ville
il est là attendrions du festival son
film par la scène mois dernier premier
league a tourné avec des moyens de
fortune il avait les plus grandes
difficultés à être montrées au public
sélectionné à cannes
il entre en compétition aujourd'hui avec
le gang de productions internationales
dans votre film le héros s'engage comme
figurant dans les enfants du paradis
vous avez été figurant dans les enfants
du paradis quelle est la part fixe et
lario bon je l'aimé parce que j'ai un
souvenir parce que c'est un peu
autobiographique mais c'est vraiment
resituer transposer et historiquement
c'est faux en 10 mai à la je vous
faisiez de la figuration dans les
enfants du paradis est flatteur bon je
voulais surtout
je voulais gagner ma vie surtout ça
n'avait pas marché comme acteur vous
aviez une vague idée de ce que non non
non si les avait pas marché comme acteur
non parce qu'en plus de ça j'avais fait
j'avais pas fait d'études juge avait
rien fait j'étais très très un recul du
trait je sais pas ce que j'aurais fait
il y a vingt ans l'un était un jeune
comédien il fut le héros du beau serge
des cousins il fut même engagé à
hollywood où alpha sylla de james dean
français pendant la ville et son
troisième c'est le troisième qui m'a
donné vraiment le plus de membres et on
aime j'étais sur deux films qui avait
relativement connu des échecs
commerciaux et financiers
c'est laisser le troisième qui a été
vraiment la croix et la bannière ça a
été l'enfer car l'enfer ces coiffes et
tourne et que malgré tout celle en
cinéma depuis 25 ans 30 ans même presque
quand je téléphone un producteur m'a
distributeurs sur toutes les portes me
sont ouverts et puis une fois qu'on a lu
le scénario
on ne m'aurait plomb on ne répond plus
et effectivement ça peut ne pas
intéresser les producteurs parce qu'il
n'ya pas d'acteurs connus
il n'y a pas il n'y a rien au départ qui
fasse que c'est une affaire facilement
montables ce que je reproche c'est que
les gens soient impoli et indélicat et
qu'on ne me répondent plus au téléphone
qu'on me donne le bon scénario à la
standardiste passé ne cherche à la
standardiste et je peux plus là mais les
avoir alors ça c'est très déplaisant que
c'est quand même des petites
humiliations comme ça enfin tout ça ne
les paie turpitudes humaines
alors de quoi vite on part dans un fort
tard porte
et puis surtout quand on est marié qu'on
a trois enfants trois fils c'est
compliqué ou vend des cheveux sont là on
fait la synchro un peu de synchro temps
en temps que je me débrouille pour marc
question si on me demandait de tourner
je tournerai volontiers aux amateurs
parce que ça assurerait au moins dans
l'intérieur